so we begin in senegal where they are
running battles between protesters and
police on the streets of the capital
dakar
after a court decided that opposition
politician usman sonko
should remain in custody violence broke
out two days ago after sonko was
arrested for taking part in an
unauthorized rally
he's also facing rape charges which he
denies saying the accusation is part of
a plot to block him
from running for president in 2024.
let's bring in nicholas hack who's
covering this protest for us from dakar
quite some unusual scenes on the streets
of
dakar today nicholas tell us about
what's been happening these past few
hours
well yes we're in front of one of the
main arteries of the capital
normally at this time of the day it's
bustling with traffic
look at it now at the very end of the
road here are protesters who earlier on
were
chanting libere which means in french
free sanco they're met with police
that in security forces who have shot
tear gas but
on this roundabout also the military
have been deployed
for reinforcement and in front
of the military apc unit a total gas
station a french
gas station that was ramsacked late last
night by protesters we've seen
a night of unprecedented violence here
in senegal not only
in the capital dakar but throughout the
country
we've seen protesters attack
cars on the highway attacked french
gas station supermarkets as well
as a police station
in the region of gejuai so really a high
level
of violence still despite the presence
of the military and all these security
forces
no no firing of live bullets they're
using tear gas they're trying to contain
the crowd
right it would seem from what you're
saying nicholas
and the fact that this is becoming
widespread now that the protests are not
just about the arrests of usman's uncle
that's right i mean it's not just about
sanko because this country has gone
through a very difficult year
through the coronavirus pandemic the
government put restrictive measures
and that's very difficult for many of
the protesters here who are
day laborers who'd rely on their daily
income to go about their business and
when there was a curfew put in place
abruptly earlier in the month of
february
restricting movement at night well that
put a lot of people
without jobs and last year in fact
during the coronavirus pandemic
for the first time in in decades people
in senegal were reliant on
food aid so the the coronavirus uh
pandemic and the economic fallout of it
has had a heavy impact
on people now president mike has called
on on debt relief to try to manage the
situation but
it's it's more than that it's really a
feeling from protesters that
they want their voices heard that they
feel that they're not being heard by
their government
but there's also the political aspect in
all this and the fact that president
mchisal has been accused of trying to
stifle the opposition
of trying to uh prevent the opposition
from
from organizing itself and participating
in elections
that's right and in fact the opposition
accused specifically president makissa
of using the courts
to eliminate its political
uh rivals starting with the son of the
former president abdullah
karimwa that was charged with corruption
and then there was
the mayor the former mayor of descartes
khalifa who we just saw drove by
in a show of support to these protesters
who was again
charged with corruption making him
illegible uh unelegible to to run for
for office us mansonko is a political
outsider he describes himself
as the anti-establishment um
candidate and politician he wants to be
the next president
of this country and he's been uh really
attacking the president quite
directly accusing him and his family of
corruption
of amassing wealth whilst most people
live on less than two dollars a day
he accuses the government also of
playing into the hands of france the
former colonial power
allowing uh french companies to operate
freely
and and and not doing enough to protect
um ordinary senegalese so
all those emotions are wrapped up in the
protest that you see behind me and
in fact you can see it in the in the in
the chanting it's not just free sanko
people have been calling for dignity uh
simply put
um really a sense that they really want
to get
they want to see some change in their uh
political
um elite or or the government so that
their um issues or their problem
problems are resolved by them
folly nick thank you very much for that
update nicholas hike with the latest
on the situation in dakar senegal which
we'll keep a close eye on
here on al jazeera of course